[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  George Floyd George Floyd George Floyd  repeatedly told the officers that he  could not breathe after an officer knelt  on his neck the family of George Floyd  held a memorial in his memory  boy named George Floyd you are gone but  not forgotten  because of you we've come together this  for George Floyd  to March  to dance  [Music]  [Applause]  - meal  to be quiet  we're seeing your name we're seeing  their names  [Music]  reading loud ravine brain  [Applause]  [Music]  we're laughing we're crying  getting engaged we're getting married  we're changing the world  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we soldiers manage stop hurt each other  and let's get it right match today is  the day we're gonna stand up for our  community man if we could do this we  could do more we just gotta continue and  push it don't give up  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]